she literally thinks you're gonna like
coming for her as her wording guess what
I am Khloe Kardashian is ready to
confront her momager Kris Jenner I've
been looking for mom forever she's
literally avoiding me and I know
yesterday stop yeah we went over to like
that little place and West like to go
get like little stuff for the house like
salt shakers and like why on earth would
she be ignoring me in a sneak peek at
Keeping Up with the Kardashians Scott
Disick tells the reality star that Kris
is avoiding her following the release of
Lamar Odom's memoir darkness to light
she's scared that you're gonna confront
her about that SoulCycle thing got to be
kidding good literally I think it's
judging me
yes she's like I don't want to see
because I don't want to have a
conversation in Lamar's best-selling
book he details an incident from 2015
where he ambushed Khloe while she was
heading into a 6:00 a.m. SoulCycle class
and he blames Kris for setting up the
headline-making moment that's all i'ma
talk about as it's a bad moment
he writes quote Chris called me later
that night to tell me that Khloe wanted
to speak to me in person
I was desperate to talk to her I knew
this was my last chance
Lamar claims that the one-way paparazzi
would have known about the SoulCycle
interaction was from Chris you hopped in
a car to come see Khloe you drove down
with the best intentions because you
thought you gonna see your wife yeah
that was crazy cuz you arrived and all
of a sudden TMZ's in your face it was
crazy and and then the headline is Lamar
is acting crazy yeah yeah it was crazy
first of all it's 600 years ago I don't
give it especially for you to ignore me
and not see you Karen yes I'm more
annoyed and literally I would have just
given her a hard time like it's creating
way more glass you're a crazy [ __ ] of
course Scott and Khloe being the
pranksters that they are we got to find
a way
just expose mom look you mean just wanna
get her face-to-face yeah yeah they came
up with a plan to corner Chris I could
say I'm sick she'll always come over if
I same say we lure her in and then you
just come out of another door yeah hey
guess who's your mother you know I'm not
gonna like jump alright just because if
you're gonna jump her all like set up a
cab
yeah no no she's gonna get so annoyed I
can't wait when et caught up with Lamar
in September he shared this update on
his relationship with Chloe and the
Kardashian family following their 2016
divorce how was your relationship with
the rest of the Kardashian family
especially Chris how was it oh how is it
now I'm you know I really haven't really
hung out we don't really have much of a
relationship now do you think Chris had
your best interests at heart I think she
did or was she protecting the brand I
mean while she's always gonna protect
her brand you know she's great at that
mm-hmm she's always gonna do that and
I'm not mad at her for doing that if you
could say one thing to Chloe right now
what would you say I love you and thank
you for being there for me when I can't
walk or talk you know when you when you
marry someone afternoon for 30 days I
don't think that love will go away
mm-hmm I'm saying a piece of paper that
says that we're not together that love
will never go away
[Music]